the love is blind reunion is out now and
I just have to ask you right off the bat
how relieved are you both that you noun
can be yourselves to the world what's
the longest you've ever held your breath
we were able to really love each other
since the show wrapped a little bit more
deeply and just more in a less pressured
environment so like our love thrived but
having to keep that under wraps was just
like this was part of my life out there
that I'm not able to talk about and then
really hard we got to unpack that
because this is roses and puppies and
beautiful but it in this way with you
all on the show so I'm like how did they
get back here holding hands being real
cute because we saw the I don't yeah
with you two and so I wonder number one
because oh god it was heartbreaking
did you actually breakup and then how
long do you stay apart or was it
immediate like okay we got to make
figure out a way to make this work
somehow after the wedding I felt like we
weren't done there's still some
unfinished business right so I reached
out to him couple hours afterwards oh
yeah cuz I'm direct I get to the point
she went right back Adam is so you
didn't even let it kind of sit for a
while I'm really I can I can really just
assess things and go through all the
emotions anger sadness understanding
acceptance that's really what happened
in such a short timeframe throughout
that whole show so you know me reaching
back out to him a couple hours
afterwards I was just like I need to
know what happened I want to understand
what you said because he also said
things you know I do want to still be
with you I still want to explore a
relationship with you well here's my
question do you mean why didn't you tell
her beforehand why'd you wait until the
wedding or was that part of the deal
that you had to go ahead and tell her at
the altar yeah so the you can
technically for
discuss things I guess right nobody can
really stop you from doing that
engagements were all their own
completely unscripted the whole show was
right but once you got engaged you had
to make it an alter okay
right and well you didn't have to
because Carlton and diamond didn't y'all
too we don't know they made it to Mexico
so I don't know what happened with all
that we didn't know they were in Mexico
with no it went sideways as you know now
it went real sideways I mean there's
probably something there that you know
was I don't know we didn't know about
but in our agreement we had to make it
an altar and but besides that I mean you
do hear me up there say I do not and it
was because I wanted to say I do so bad
why okay but let me ask you this knowing
that you are going to devastate this
woman yeah who loves you
why didn't you give her some kind of
signal or something ahead of time cuz I
didn't know until the moment of I have
to tell you I do not was woo that was a
killer yeah I was I wanted to hold I do
but it was just so it's it's hard to
believe I go by the day and take away
all the pain that she went through and
the embarrassment I would in a heartbeat
would I stand by my decision yes who and
your family wanted to kill him there's a
lot of us but I think my mom was just
the most hurt yeah because she didn't
want to see her baby be rejected like
that but you know back to the point of
just like he didn't know I didn't know
throughout you know because you would
say she was actually the one that was
more hot and cold than you so was it
more so like I need to make sure that
you're sure before I say I do yeah so
there there was a lot of back-and-forth
and it's something I can't hold against
her we were both put in extreme
circumstances in a very small period of
time and I can be a very understanding
person I should as can she but when you
have all these mixed elements you you
have to have a wedding we're planning
we're back at work at our jobs there's a
lot of stress you're living with
somebody you just met it's hot and there
was a lot of back and cold you know she
didn't believe in ideals of traditional
marriage yeah because there's a lot that
comes with kids yeah which was standing
outside a bus so there's a lot of
missing stuff that wasn't shown about
our story in the
that led up to that right and but
there's so many things that come with
marriage you're talking about kids
combining finances moving in together
right and she's a free spirit
she likes to fly and you know in that
decision I was like this may seem like
we have to do it but I want us to be
best friends first I want to be her soul
mate and I want to make sure that it
works without the pressures of the
wedding speaking of flying yeah you went
flying down that hill but when we saw
you talk to him like you were all clean
oh yeah right so what happened there was
that time line play out because you
should have been dirty your dress should
have been dirty yeah but you don't wanna
look dirty no one's like dirty right so
after you know I took that little tumble
got back up dusted myself off cleaned it
because if I'm gonna confront this man
that I'm angry
I want to you know feel my best
it's like scrubbed it my mom was just
like what are you doing stop that get
out of that dress I'm like no mom I need
to clean it like cuz I wanted to just
take that away you know I wanted to
literally just clean and like kind of
restart I love the fact that you guys
are so happy and I'm really glad you
made your way back to each other but you
know I have to ask how long are you
gonna date her are you gonna marry her
again soon would you like to get engaged
right here because you could do it today
yeah it's a great question
it's not off the table but I want to
make sure that it's done right it's not
beautiful and this time you know is the
last time so I what does that mean it's
not off the table
does that mean it's not off the table to
get engaged again or married right you
know so are you being are you being very
cautious because you said before I
wanted to say I do like I want to marry
this woman so like it's not off the
table hold on I mean cautious are you
just being a little coy I don't know I
just I want to make sure it's it's right
timing for both of us there's a lot
going on in our lives right now and
throwing you know another wedding and
bring a family better than all that on
top of it is it to suit for your family
I'm just in general I feel like I would
want it to be more intimate or just
because I was I knew that this
experiment was gonna bring an engagement
I just want to be surprised
relaxed not know it's coming see I know
your family would be like ain't no way
and we gonna go get off right so that's
why I'm saying yeah we will never go do
this again oh no they love Damien okay
and it's all good they love him and they
have like all these inside jokes my
family my whole family wasn't at the
wedding so I missed you know Mike Senate
family being there so yeah they were so
you're ready you're ready but I believe
in obvious I believe in opposites
attract and I feel like you guys like
she's fire your ice you know what I'm
saying and I like how that works so I
wonder like fire did you have you broken
up again
have you had times where you're like I
can't do this okay I can't again or have
you guys gotten back together and stayed
together since the I don't that's it we
definitely had our moments I mean it's
it wasn't just you come by together and
everything's like BAM it's great it took
a lot of work it took a lot of us
developing good communication with each
other I'll tell you this I've never been
in a relationship like this in my life
but it's beautiful she challenges me
every day and we have had our moments
where we're like we just need time apart
but we're not really a part of that we
call each other back look I'm sorry this
this is my fault
did you hear that what magical way he
navigated that just now you're really
good he said yeah they've kind of broken
up
[Music]